activision finally revealed the details
of call of duty vanguard's upcoming
integration into warzone let's break
down the details and dates for these
upcoming events including post-launch
content and when you can play the new
warzone map for more updates about
warzone vanguard and more remember to
subscribe to gamespot
[Music]
season 1 starts on december 2nd bringing
a new warzone pacific map called caldera
that will introduce new modes including
aerial dogfighting prior to the start of
warzone pacific players will also get
limited time modes in verdansk to say
goodbye to the map as well as learn
information about caldera before the
integration before season 1 war zones
verdance map will also get two final
events
first operation flashback is described
as an encore forever dance which begins
on november 18th this is a limited time
mode that is said to feature plenty of
surprises that cover verdansk's history
over the last 18 months
operation flashback will reward two
unique items an emblem for participating
in the event and an animated calling
card for those who claim victory this
goodbye for for dance is very vague but
activision says more information on
operation flashback will be revealed
prior to its launch on november 18th
starting on november 24th players will
be able to collect intel to uncover more
about the caldera map through another
limited time event called secrets of the
pacific this event is developed by b
knox and will give players intel on
caldera and its various points of
interest prior to its launch in december
but only by completing challenges across
vanguard and warzone this sounds much
like past seasonal events in black ops
cold war and war zone as each game will
have its own set of tasks and rewards
for completing them more details on this
event are coming mid-november however it
does tease that verdance might get blown
up again
finally caldera will arrive on december
2nd with the launch of season 1.
call of duty war zone is a free to play
game but vanguard players will get 24
hours of exclusive access to the new
caldera map at the start of season 1.
during this exclusive access warzone's
smaller rebirth island map will remain
unlocked for everyone else to play
additionally activision said that
caldera's only true comparison to
verdansk is its scale the island is
described as featuring lush forests and
rocky crags as well as the white sand
beaches and mysterious ruins there is
also a dormant volcano that towers over
the map which activision boasts as
having 200 plus points of interest
activision also says that the caldera
design is based on two years of research
and listening to the community warzone
pacific will introduce a dog fighting
mode vanguard royale is a new mode that
will allow players to take on the skies
and maneuver aa guns to combat aerial
attacks later in season 1 players can
expect a return of verdansk's plunder
mode which has players fighting to earn
the most cash for a win players can also
use all of their modern warfare and
black ops cold war weapons for both
rebirth island and standard modes on
caldera only certain playlists like the
new dogfighting mode will limit the
weapon pool to vanguard's weapons only
warzone pacific will also bring the
arrival of the recently revealed
ricochet anti-cheat to hopefully cut
back on warzone's ongoing cheating
problem
and being built on the same tech and
engine as call of duty vanguard warzone
pacific will support fully optimized
cross-play cross-progression and
cross-gen support
outside of this massive upcoming warzone
integration vanguard is also shaping up
for a big first season at launch during
pre-season vanguard will offer 20
multiplayer maps four of them being
dedicated gunfight maps and 16 for 6v6
and higher confirmed modes include team
deathmatch kill confirmed domination
search and destroy hardpoint champion
hill and patrol vanguard's new mode
where players control a moving hardpoint
two more upcoming modes were also
announced but not revealed activision
says these two modes are expected
sometime shortly after launch
12 operators have also been confirmed
for launch the group dubbed task force
one will offer your standard fare of
customization options including battle
quips and skins
due to vanguard are infiltration poses
which come before a match
the gunsmith returns and with more than
30 weapons at launch players will have
several options for weapon customization
this includes over 200 attachments
across all classes 10 slots per weapon
and a choice of 40 unique weapon perks
to choose from vanguard says this
overhauled gunsmith system will make for
incredibly deep possibilities with your
loadout and lastly for pre-season the
fan favorite map shipment comes to
vanguard on november 17th as we move
into season 1 on december 2nd we see
even more content drops for vanguard
confirmed are two new operators three
multiplayer maps updates to zombies mode
and of course over 100 tiers of battle
pass items ranging from emblems and
charms to unlockable weapons and
blueprints
with lots of call of duty coming our way
very soon subscribe to gamespot for our
upcoming review of vanguard live streams
gameplay and more thanks for watching
[Music]
you